en vampire en sorcière ou encore en
zombies chaque année le 31 octobre se
pose la question comment se déguiser
pour la soirée d'halloween accessoires
en tout genre maquillage effrayant dents
de vampires ou encore hache ensanglantée
les petits comme les grands ne recule
devant rien pour effrayer leurs proches
boucher charcutier
c'est vraiment très bien alors j'ai eu
un choix et j'ai découpé non j'aime bien
loupé c'est sympa ça peut faire peur aux
gens de leur demander des bonbons s'ils
veulent pas mourir dans les rayons il y
a l'embarras du choix
les clients recherchent la tenue la plus
terrifiante j'ai déjà trouvé
alors c'est quoi je ne sais pas trop on
verra ses maquillages qui fait tout
c'est important à l'ordre ou non mais
c'est juste pour s'amuser comme ça
d'autres misent davantage sur les
accessoires pour terroriser leur
voisinage
j'ai des bonbons au chaos je ferai pas
peur à tout le monde mais j'ai des tas
piqûre des squelettes qui s'allument je
vais avoir des toiles d'araignées la
chercher en fait des espèces de grands
sacs en tête de mort pour remplir de
feuilles mortes des choses comme ça côté
budget vous pourrez exprimer votre
créativité sans faire frissonner votre
porte monnaie avec une tenue complète
pour moins de 40 euros
et cette année la tendance des
déguisements est au clown maléfique
adultes et enfants les masques les
tenues le maquillage c'est vrai qu'on
ait beaucoup aidé aussi par la sortie du
film ça donc tout le monde recherche
vraiment dû du clown effrayant ça le
célèbre clown au ballon qui a terrorisé
toute une génération risque donc
d'envahir vos rues dès ce soir
à